we know who our enemies are the isis k
the isis you know the taliban the list
goes on and on and on who are our
biggest
allies
in the middle east right and where they
house like these where did these where
were these guys
based out of obviously we know israel
who else is on our list of allies we
know the enemies who are the allies so
so to me it's it's kind of a tough
question because it depends on on what
position you take and who you are even
within our government
uh having said that jordan historically
has been what i would consider probably
our biggest ally in the region outside
of israel
um i i don't thank saudi for a number of
reasons which would be its own episode
by itself uh you know doesn't have any
of our best interests in mind 911 being
a clear-cut example
and in all the rest of the countries
it's it's not that black and white as
far as just like with with our country
right is that you've got even within our
government you've got people on polar
opposite spectrums of so there's no
countries other than israel or jordan
you would put on that list what about
regions or types like the kurds we'd
always hear about the kurds or great
fighters and they were fighting against
yeah the northern third of iraq is is
generally a a considerable ally for us
but we've turned our back on them a few
times and totally sold them out so
you know to say that there are a staunch
ally and we can depend on them i
wouldn't say i remember trump caught a
lot of heat about pulling out and
basically
people don't recall as much heat as
biden took in afghanistan for the sloppy
withdrawal there was a brief period of
time where trump was taking a lot of
heat from abandoning the kurds not as
big as afghanistan because though people
don't know that but do you recall that
not really um you know and maybe that's
uh maybe that's the media portion i
don't know i you know to me the the the
abandonment of them happened well before
he got in office i mean it happened four
years prior to that it happened in my
opinion midway through obama's term so
to me to depend pin that on
on trump i think is uh is disingenuous
because it's
the rise of of isis took place halfway
through obama's term with without
question so when he called him the jv uh
yeah and he just you know he pulled
basically all of the the territory that
we had territory uh you know all of the
regions and areas in iraq that we
had fought so hard to secure just like
we did in afghanistan and basically just
pulled everybody back
uh withdrew almost every troop from from
the region and just let
isis steamroll through there and and
just i mean the things that they did
there was
i mean hard to even wrap your mind
around and and that took place for years
before trump came out does the united
states always always always need to have
a presence in the middle east i don't
think so no i really i don't think so no
i mean i i take much more of a
i would say bordering on isolationist
viewpoint uh in terms of foreign policy
at this point i mean to me i reduce
or i i tend to reduce foreign policy all
the way down to such a micro level like
a bar fight right and to me they're
they're interchangeable that way is that
you're walking uh by your favorite club
right and there's a huge fight going on
now you can walk in there and you can
help the guy that has four dudes pinning
him down and bashing his head in or you
can help the woman that's getting
slapped around you know whatever it is
just by walking in there you're going to
piss somebody off
no matter who you help you're going to
piss somebody off and you're going to
create enemies right and so
to me i think world war ii is the most
clear-cut example on how to handle
things at a at a geopolitical or
international level where you don't get
involved until you have to but when you
do you take the [ __ ] gloves off and
you go over there until the job is done
and you do whatever is necessary to come
to sherman style from the civil war but
isn't that what we did
after 9 11
we were kind of out for about two months
we were out of afghanistan
and then we went no qatar bahrain saudi
i mean
exercises in jordan
joint operations in israel we've been
heavily footprinted in the middle east
way more than we need to be for decades
i mean it started back in in honestly
when
when the first persian gulf uh war took
place and and you know we got bombed in
in saudi arabia for being there i mean
that that's really when when it really
started in my opinion where
uh the hardline group specifically al
qaeda i mean that that was born out of
saudi allowing us to have troops in in
the region uh to defend kuwait that
pissed osama bin laden off to the point
where
he created al-qaeda because of that so
um you know to me there there's been a
lot of involvement that we've had that's
that's unnecessarily created problems
that
you know that that we're we're still
paying for and these people
fear the united states military for sure
they do they do 100 and even just as
recent as
seven months ago that the fact that we
had 2500 troops in afghanistan and they
still weren't doing anything until biden
was like yeah we're actually leaving and
they closed down the air base
the fact that that just 2500 troops held
the uh the taliban at bay because you
saw how fast they took the country over
right it was supposed to be months and
then right literally was days it wasn't
2500 troops it was the fact that we
still had a presence there and they knew
if they tried to do that while we still
were taking the stance of we are here
that it would have been 2.0 afghanistan
we would have come back in and they
would have paid for it i mean you can
see it in their operations with
um
attacking certain bases and
knowing when you know how long they have
before you know close air support is
going to be there i mean there's a
healthy respect for it or they would
have done what they did seven months ago
18 years ago
there's a reason they didn't do it that
entire time
how how worried should we be that we
left behind what was it 80 billion
dollars of military equipment i mean at
this point to be worried about it i
think is fruitless but uh is it is it a
kick in the gut yes absolutely uh do i
think that they're gonna take those
assets and and now
you know uh
launch attacks in into america no i
don't i think it sucks is it going to
turn them into
an overnight success no it isn't i mean
if you look at how much money we put
into
forces in iraq and afghanistan and doing
you know foreign internal defense with a
lot of other countries over there
you know we we've spent at this point
trillions of dollars on equipment and
training i mean i i've worked with guys
before
to have the capabilities that the united
states has takes a whole another level
of
uh generational dedication that that
just isn't there you know so am i
worried about it ultimately no does it
piss me off yes it does so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you